- [Interviewer] Okay Fred, you ready?
- (silly voice) Cool, man!
(series of sound effects: dog
bark, squeak, plane, whistle)
(whistling, drum kit sounds)
- [Interviewer] I'll take that as a "Yes.”
This is Fred Newman.
- Hey!
- [Interviewer] What do you do, Fred?
- I honk for a living. (makes horn sound)
I worked on a Nickelodeon
show called Doug.
(playful music)
I did the sound design and music.
♫ Do-Da do-da-do-da do-da doo-a doo
That wasn't Doug's voice,
that was actually my voice.
We wanted to use as much as
we could household objects,
things that a kid would have.
Make it sound innocent
'cause this is a kid's diary.
I tended to do a lot of
things with my mouth:
(rhythm and musical sounds).
- [Doug] Dear Journal,
have you ever been so broke
you had to cash in your pennies?
- [Interviewer] Not only did Fred work
on the sounds and music,
but was also a voice for
a bunch of the characters.
- Porkchop the dog, (barks and whines).
He would actually kinda
talk but not quite.
"Roooorooo?"
Skeeter.
- It's short for Mosquito!
- Cool, man! You know, he
had the little honk (honks).
"Hey, Doug! How ya doin’, man?"
I saw he had a big nose; I
just thought he would always
have this sort of adenoid thing going on,
lot of post-nasal drip.
Bud Dink--
- Welcome, newcomer!
- Had big Chiclet teeth
(laughs as character)
and his name was Dink because
of Double Income No Kids.
The Beets: ♫ I've made more
allowance, yodel-ay-eee
♫ Killer Tofuuuu
And that was kind of based
on Sting a little bit.
- [Interviewer] While Doug may be
Fred's claim to fame in our eyes,
he does all kinds of sounds
for movies, TV, and radio.
His first movie was Gremlins.
- I came and did the bad
guy, Stripe. (snarls)
(snarling)
Some of them are cute (speaking Gremlin)
I did the sound when the Mogwai
turned into the bad guys.
(wet bubbling and creepy oozing noises)
- [Interviewer] But Fred's often on screen
when you don't even realize it.
- I did a lot of dogs in movies.
I will go (dog whimper), you've gotta put
real human emotions coming
out of animals or doors.
The door has to sound
sad when you open it up.
(creaking door)
That's where I get called in.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
let's try a couple. Horse.
(heavy horse breathing)
Weasel.
(squeaking and squealing)
Aliens?
(silly language)
Birds?
(tweeting)
Vibration?
- Ug-ug-ug-ug-ug-ug-ug-ug!
(gentle piano music)
The message I say is,
"Whatever makes you weird.
"Go there. And pursue that." (bird calls)
Mine is sound; I never
thought for a second I could
do that for a living (bird calls)
but here I am!
As the sun sinks slowly in the west,
we bid you all a fond farewell.
(musical nostril tones)